- Smile.
- [Mark] So, Reilly, you're back again.
- [Reilly] I'm back again.
- Or Russia, isn't it?
Everyone calls you Russia on the street.
- [Reilly] They didn't understand that,
that Reilly wasn't a
Russian name (chuckles).
- [Mark] I call you Reilly,
which is actually your last name, right?
- Yeah.
That's what I like.
- [Mark] Okay, I remember I asked you
what your name was and
what do they call you,
you said Reilly, so that's what stuck.
- Right.
- [Mark] So, what's going on, please?
- Oh, well, I've got a million stories.
- [Mark] I know you do.
- I'll forget them because I have PTSD
and all of a sudden something
will make me remember something.
You know, I can't put them
in chronological order,
I can't remember when they happened.
This one happened when I was young.
I can't remember where the hotel is at.
But anyway, I was working at a dance club
and I was living in one of those hotels
where nobody talks, everything's,
nothing's seen, nothing's heard.
- [Mark] Yes.
- And next door to me was this man
and then his two children.
One was he said 17, I doubt it.
And the other one was six.
And two girls, there were two girls.
And he was one of these men
that had that schlurpy Jheri curl
with all the juicy dripping,
gold teeth in the mouth.
He was a pimp.
'Cause he kept trying to get at me
and I'd be like, kind of a hostile guy.
And then one day, I was
getting off the elevator
and maybe you have to understand,
I have molestation issues.
I'm not able to just let things pass by
when I see other children or kids
and things happen to them.
So, I got in this elevator
and I stepped off and there
was nobody left, right,
at the exit of the elevator.
But then I heard like crying.
And I turned around and back in the day,
they had those kind of trash cans,
they were kind of a dome
and the top was like a little ash tray.
And I looked behind it and
there's this little girl
who's six years old, my neighbor.
And she's crying and she
has blood all in her,
she had these little shorts on.
And I said, "What happened?"
And she said, "No, no, no."
And I said, "Baby, you
want me to get your dad?"
"No, no, don't get him, he'll be so mad
because I made the trick mad."
And my brain just snapped.
Made the trick mad.
- [Mark] Made the what?
- [Reilly] Trick mad.
She made the trick mad.
- [Mark] The trick.
- [Reilly] The trick.
He had pimped her out to somebody
and he had, you know, sex with her
and she was bleeding.
- [Mark] This is the six-year-old?
- [Reilly] It was the six-year-old girl.
And I said, "Do you want me to take,
you can come on over, do you
want me to call your mother?"
"No, she'll just sell me back."
So I took her to my room.
And I just came from, I had gone to this,
my friend had a new tanning salon
in Beverly Hills with
the high-pressure beds
and I had gotten really crispy work
and so I'd stopped by a store
and they had this sale on this,
that I'd never seen before,
green rubbing alcohol.
And I was use it to put in my bath water
to take the sting out out of the sunburn.
And I bought a case, it
was like 39 cents a bottle.
So, I bought a box of it.
And I took this little girl to my room
and I tried to clean
her up in the bathroom
and I was trying to talk real calm to her
because she was damaged goods.
She was just six years old.
I mean, how do you? I
know, I was there before.
So, I just knew I couldn't
let that man have her back.
He came later on,
he pounds on my door.
A neighbor had seen me
take her into my room
and I had filled up a bucket
with that rubbing alcohol
and when he pounded on that door,
I knew he was gonna come in there
and take that little girl from me,
so I threw that bucket
of rubbing alcohol at him
and I lit it.
And he was wearing, I
remember he was wearing
a green Puma jogging suit when
they first started coming out
and he ran down this hallway on fire.
And there was all these
big bright green flames
and his hair was plopping off,
'cause he was on fire and I pulled
the little girl in the hallway
and I said, "He will never hurt you again.
You see, he will never hurt you again."
And I pulled her back in the room
and shut the door.
And I called the office and I told them
that there was a mess in the hallway
because it was one of those hotels
where nobody talks and nobody sees.
And she had an auntie
and somehow I found how to
get a hold of this auntie.
And when I called she was just ecstatic
that I had called.
She said as soon as she had the money,
she would send it to me for the ticket
to send her back.
I said, "Don't worry about
the ticket, I got the ticket.
You just have to promise me
that you will take care of her
because she's broken."
She knows that he'll never
come and hurt her again.
I don't even know what
happened to that man.
I don't really care.
I never heard an ambulance, I don't know.
I don't care.
But I know that she's okay.
Her auntie was so happy to get her back.
She told me that her mother
would never touch her.
If her mother even tried,
she said she would kill her.
- [Mark] So the man was
a relation to the girl?
- To the little girl?
No, he wasn't.
- [Mark] He was just a pimp.
- His mother, back in
the Midwest someplace,
both of the girls were sisters
and he took them both.
She gave him some money.
He gave them some money and he took
the two little girls.
- [Mark] So...
- The one, the older one,
she liked being there I guess or something
or just kind of like that syndrome
where you're kidnapped and you-
- [Mark] So she stayed.
- Yeah, she stayed.
- [Mark] And the mother,
the auntie you were...
- The auntie.
- [Mark] Where was it?
- She was in Detroit.
- [Mark] Detroit.
- And I send her back to Detroit.
Because I couldn't keep her.
I'm not capable of being a mother.
There's too many people who are good
at being mothers.
I try, but I just wasn't too good.
I knew that I did what I
was I was supposed to do.
That's what I was supposed to do.
I was supposed to save her.
I was supposed to get her away from there
and then pass her on to somebody
who would be good at raising a child.
- [Mark] I don't know if a lot of people
could do what you did.
- I can't think of any other
way I could have done that.
It was just like, that just seemed like,
I didn't even think about it.
Rubbing alcohol was in my hand,
this man's not gonna get this little girl.
Whatever I have to do,
this man is not gonna
get this little girl.
He's probably wearing that
same green jogging suit.
They'll probably bury him in it if he's...
I'm not quite sure what
happened to him, I don't care.
But, yeah.
It make me feel a lot better.
When I put her on the
bed, she started crying.
Because I seen it in her eyes
finally somebody helped her.
I know that feeling
because I just needed to be helped.
I'm crying.
That's a trigger of mine.
I have a trigger where I start to cry
if people are still doing something
that's really bothering me.
That's a perpetrator.
If they know that it bother you,
whatever it is they're doing bothers you,
annoys you, makes you feel uncomfortable,
but they continue to do it
for their own gratification.
That's a perpetrator.
And there's levels of that
and there's the extreme.
I say why do they keep
doing that, I'm crying.
- [Mark] In some ways,
in some way did that
event heal some of the damage-
- Yeah, it made me feel,
it made me feel, yeah.
- [Mark] Your own pain was
kind of healed by doing that.
- Absolutely.
I can't think of anything.
I couldn't have lived with myself
if I hadn't have done that.
That wasn't an option not doing something.
That wasn't an option.
I had to do that.
Whatever the case may,
as it seemed to be, the
only thing I could think of.
This man, if I opened that door
and hadn't have done something,
that man would have
taken that child from me.
- [Mark] Oh, of course he would.
- [Reilly] No matter what he had to do
to make it.
We were just some kind of a property
or a commodity.
- [Mark] Right.
- [Reilly] Hi.
- [Mark] Thank you so much
for yet another great story.
- When I think of another
one, I'll come back.
- [Mark] Yeah, you are
welcome here any time.
- Okay.
Say bye, say bye Spot.
I'm an auntie.
I always babysit people's dogs.
I make a good auntie.
- [Mark] Beautiful dog.
- [Reilly] Right, okay, are we off?